luxury sports cars cruising the streets
trending night spots opening up sorrento
today is a far cry from its beginnings
as a workers district under apartheid
see for foots Annie was born here in
1976 the year of the Soweto uprising
during which hundreds of black students
were killed by state security forces we
meet in an up-market coffee shop to talk
about the new Soweto see what can you
tell me how did select or change in the
last decades whether in the last tooth
decay so it has changed the way that you
find places where they are still live
they've got like posture has to end like
this one and also that there are malls
and the better clinics and other stuff
but it's not all over sorry tool so
there are some places we just did not
changed on improved seafood takes me on
a tour of kliptown the oldest part of
sweater little has changed here since
the days of apartheid few houses have
electricity and the smell of sewage
fills the air it's a forgotten place the
government isn't done much to serve that
these people there's no sanitation
there's no electricity it's just turned
down been like this for almost 40 years
now this many residents feel neglected
by the government their frustration
regularly erupting into violent protest
it's the middle of the South African
winter in this neighborhood often
suffers power cuts people are frustrated
that's why I painting the tires because
since yesterday we didn't have
electricity our kids slept with with
cold so now we want we want electricity
we want it now they should change at the
ANC said that everyone's vote vote vote
vote vote for for what how can they they
come and campaign for election then the
next thing they give us for service to
develop a small spark is often enough to
ignite the situation
it is more for just like this in so a
true like we experience them everything
but in seafoods opinion the protests
have little effect like many people here
he's tried a number of jobs ranging from
photographer to traditional healer a few
months Mackay opened a fast-food
restaurant with a friend for me this is
the only way to code taking my own
business not waiting for the committed
to something for me that's only way to
survive until the future Sifu says the
same goes for sorrento as a whole 40
years after the uprising here a happy
end is still a distant prospect